you look at my prediction I'm predicting
this is going to happen and you can't
see this coming but I can and the reason
I could see it coming is because I
studied this field of persuasion and I
saw this Trump character and he had the
full toolset thank you for coming that's
one anniversary reasons 50th thank you
for celebrating this is our first big
event of our of our birthday year the
other anniversary and this brings us to
Scott Adams in his book is the
anniversary of Donald Trump is president
you know and I think we're probably
mixed minds about that's not by that I
mean we dislike him or we dislike him or
not and Scott is certainly of that
Scott's book wind Bigley persuasion in a
world where facts don't matter is built
around his bold prediction back in 2016
or what did you actually have 15 15 yeah
in 2015 that Donald Trump was gonna win
and at that point he was seen as a
madman a crazy person a writer of
doodles that have fired our imagination
for you know more than 25 years but not
more than that and now you sit here with
a book which is obviously going to be a
best-seller and I think you've persuaded
what your you've won before anybody even
reads the book in terms of persuading
them that you know what you're talking
about because you were there alone we're
going to talk about his unique take on
Donald Trump as well as his contention
that he repeats again and again in the
book which is one I've learned from
reading the book is one form of
persuasion to repeat things over and
over but that quote facts don't matter
and again this is a tough sell in a
reason read his book isn't simply about
Donald Trump in contemporary politics it
represents in many ways a direct
challenge to the world that reason and
most libertarians inhabit or want to
inhabit one where logic and rationality
are not merely possible but preferable
before we start our conversation I want
to give a quick sketch of Scott's
background he was born in 1950
I've been raised and educated in upstate
New York shortly after graduating
college in 1979 he did what everybody
with half a braid in upstate New York
did in 1979 which was fly to California
and I guess you haven't take have you
ever even ever been back not in the
winter okay which means you could only
be there about three months out of the
so and he started years of working at
this the kinds of jobs that he talks
better makes fun of in Lampoon's and
satirizes in Dilbert he started at a
Crocker National Bank and I learned
earlier tonight and a off-the-record
conversation but [ __ ] it I'm gonna say
it as a bank teller as well as working
at Pacific Bell he picked up an MBA at
UC Berkeley along the way and then
launched Dilbert in 1989 the rest is
history of course still Burt helped to
define the 1990s and none of us felt
quite as alone or unappreciated in our
cubicles ever since and we knew we had
somebody who understood what was wrong
with our managers even when we were
those managers since then he's published
numerous collections nonfiction books
has won every basically every award that
you can for cartooning he's also a
trained hypnotist so you know
don't stare into his eyes too long and
he is a student of persuasion which is
precisely why he says he was able to
call Trump's victory long before it's
incredible to most everybody
particularly people like me political
journalists you know who really
virtually no one saw coming I think you
talk in the book about how Nate Silver
the blogger who made his bones by
calling I guess was the 2012 election he
called every race right every
congressional race right
he had Hillary Clinton winning with 98%
accuracy or certitude Scott took the the
2% and turned it into a victory so Scott
thanks for talking to us now we are here
pleasure now let's start by talking
about your worldview
describe yourself you're not a
conservative you are a liberal you are
actually very liberal extreme liberal
extra liberal you're taking liberalism
to the extreme how do you define like
what do you mean by that the only way to
describe it is with some examples so for
example abortion conservatives would
like to limit it liberals would
generally like to make it available
under certain conditions and I want you
they want to expand right expand it okay
and I'm even left of that where I say
that women should decide and that men
should follow their lead based on the
following logic that men don't add
anything in terms of knowledge but they
certainly don't have the same skin in
the game the same experience the you
know the lived experience and even if
you're not going to have a baby or get
pregnant you're still in the workforce
and expectations are on the yet cetera
so the most credible kind of a law
whether you've got a life-and-death
situation is the one that society will
look at and say all right even if I
don't agree with that law I that's
credible the way it was made and if
women collectively decided whatever they
decide I'm gonna back now of course I'll
decide with my own money and taxes and
stuff but so what else
how I mean so you're liberal on abortion
or extreme liberal on abortion what else
ever I suspect and again I don't want to
speak for the people in this in the room
but you know libertarians are like okay
yeah we're pro choice or we're certainly
Pro getting the government out of
people's personal lives anger us right
now
glad to help for example I have a idea
for slavery reparations
that's about as left as you can get and
the idea would be to for 25 years to
give free college to any African
American who you know is below some
income levels so it's reasonably fair
and then after 25 years say all right
you know we're we're even basically now
this is usually haven't been to college
lately that might start another
reparations round yes and so the idea is
that the you attacks only the top 1% to
fund this because the top 1% always
gains whatever society gains you know if
society gains $2 the top 1% gets ten of
it you know so if you help the people in
the deepest hole you get the biggest
bang for the buck for the people at the
top it's essentially self funding in the
long run so I mean one of the reasons
that I wanted to have Scott talk about
his his political world viewer is
ideologies upfront is that over at the
time that he was blogging about Trump
and about Trump's likely victory people
were accusing him of being a you know a
trump supporter in a kind of basic way
of that he wanted to advance Donald
Trump's agenda as opposed to observing
it so I mean that's part of it I want to
give you some separation from the guy
you're talking about and it's really
about the process which comes through
very well and win big Lee now you write
on page 37 that the main theme of this
book is that humans are not rational I
was expecting us yeah it hurts too it
hurts to hear that because the first
issue of Reason fifty years ago
promised the readers that we will trade
in quote logic not legends and quote
coherence not contradictions so what's
the evidence that humans are not
rational or swayed by facts and
argumentation well I'll tell you how I
came to it and then I'll give you the
the scientific part of it what I studied
to be a hypnotist and this was the early
eighties I guess one of the things you
have to understand in order to be a
hypnotist as the people are irrational
90% of the time but they don't know it
you know we do have the capacity to be
rational but only on stuff we don't care
about right so you know it was a
rational process
this for me to figure out how to get
from my house to here right and several
ways to do it all rational but if you
had added just a little bit of emotion
to that ration just goes out the window
and you can't even be a hypnotist until
you understand people as fundamentally
irrational now since then there's a huge
body of evidence if you read books like
influence by Robert she'll Dini
you know Thinking Fast and Slow there's
a book called a habit there's so there's
now all kinds of science that gets at
the same point from different directions
that we think we're rational but it
turns out face book and change your vote
no and you don't even know why you just
know you were looking at you know
postings of your family and suddenly you
you like that other candidate a little
bit better so at this point it's no
longer sort of the intuitive feeling
that old hypnotists had it was just sort
of their their lived experience it's now
backed by science and you can see in the
Trump phenomenon you surely you know
people who have high IQs who completely
disagree with you right now in the old
days I used to say well one of them is
wrong right there's there's a right one
and there's a wrong one and I was always
quite lucky because I was always the
right one no matter what situation there
was I was always the right one and then
I realize everybody thinks that about
themselves and so it turns out that a
clearer picture of our human existence
is that we are rationalizing we are not
rational and that we're indeed creating
what I call a movie in our head to
explain the facts but here's the
interesting thing we can look at the
same facts and support two completely
different movies you see that and maybe
you'll be asking me about this but in
the the Trump phenomenon we're all
looking at the same news for the most
part you know there's a little silos but
the big stuff is all the same and the
Trump supporters are saying well look
what he's done to the economy and the
anti-trump errs
saying you mean Obama's economy there's
there's just nothing that can't be seen
through both movies and only rarely do
they conflict to the point where you
just have to solve one of them and and
from that point on you know both movies
can see the same fact so if we are not
rational where do our to sit like how
did decisions get made via emotion or
what what goes into that so I you know
and certainly with Trump you know he has
the worst approval ratings he had the
worst approval ratings and you know of
any modern political or presidential
candidate Hillary was second second
worse but where where do those
perceptions come from if they're
emotionally driven well let's talk about
approval ratings I don't think they mean
what they used to mean when I was
younger I remember the the talk in
politics was there's not there's not a
dime a difference between the Democrats
and the Republican so in that world if
you supported one of them but the other
one got elected you could say well you
know I'm warming up to that other one
they weren't that different from the
start but now you have Donald Trump he's
just not like anything else right so if
you didn't like him it's this huge
mental leap you would have to have to
support him so instead because you're
your worldview got upset when he won you
know most of the world believed it was
literally just impossible he could win
and that was of course reinforced by the
news they said the same thing right up
until Election Day well halfway through
Election Day right so this is the
perfect setup for something called
cognitive dissonance
now cognitive dissonance is that moment
when the thing you know to be true is
clearly and unambiguously not true and
instead of saying oh I guess I learned
something today I'm a big [ __ ] idiot
right sorry but people don't do that
they say oh I guess the Russians got him
in so you need to have a reason why a
reason why you were always logical and
you were well even if you weren't Aang's
exactly right you are pretty right and
we're all doing that all the time but
only for the emotional questions and
politics is clearly in that look at
marriage for example half of them
respect when you say that you mean let's
look at four we'll get to the half of
them don't work and of the half that
appear up apparently work well maybe
half of them are as happy as they should
be and the ones that are happy and will
stick to that story there may be a
little cognitive dissonance explaining
why did I do this crazy thing it's not
making me happy oh I guess I am happy so
science has much support for this idea
that we rationalize quite easily right
well and speaking of happiness you talk
about how we use filter do you know
engage the world I mean that's this
green kind of through which we see the
world and you say that good filter or
ones that make us happy and predict the
best correctly explain that yeah so once
you well I give it I have to give you a
little bit more background when I first
came to San Francisco my girlfriend's at
the time talked me into taking mushrooms
and I got what's that it's a water the
only time I've ever done that and you
experience a reality that where all the
stuff you understand like you know what
this is and you know what it does and
how to lift it and everything else but
you're seeing it like you're an alien
who came to the planet and had never
seen these things but you just knew
about them so everything looked new and
different but everything worked and that
this was the big aha that you can see
things through a completely different
filter a different movie if you will and
you can still get to work you can still
eat you still do all your stuff but that
plus hypnosis plus you know a lot of
reading on persuasion
taught me that if I say that my version
of reality is true I'm probably an idiot
the best you can say is that you've got
a filter unreality that either does a
good job of predicting and making you
happy or it doesn't that's as good as
you can do so when I started talking
about Trump in the election I said watch
this I'm going to predict what happens
in a very unlikely situation so I told
people from the start don't don't ask me
later how I got it right because
everybody can rationalize the past you
look at my prediction I'm predicting
this is going to happen and you can't
see this coming but I can and the reason
I could see it coming is because I
studied this field of persuasion and I
saw this Trump character and he had the
full tool set and if you don't know what
the tools are you don't recognize them
and so I watched this this monster come
into our consciousness and and I was
like in the dream like there's a monster
there's a monster everybody everybody
you don't know what's happening you
don't know what's gonna happen this is
way bigger than you think he's not gonna
go away in a month he's not the crazy
clown no it's a trick it's a trick he's
gonna be your president now of course I
was considered like just a raving you
know idiot for those times to your
credit reason was the first big outlet
that took me seriously well sure there
you go and you know put me on on a video
saying that you would win and why you'd
win with with the set of tools well and
you talk about it in the book and we'll
dig into Trump specifically but you talk
about master persuaders and these are
people who are really good at getting
the world to bend to their version of it
what are the characteristics of a master
persuader
so my ranking of persuaders are people
like me are commercial persuaders
meaning I use it for my work so I
learned persuasion because it helps me
write Alice May cartoon and helps me
speak you know understanding how
people's brains are wired helps you to
communicate in every way above me would
be cognitive scientists the people who
have actually you know done
the work and they've they've seen more
things that I've seen and they know off
if you use this this burnt orange color
on your interface people are going to
click on it at 13% more more often I
mean they're there at that level and
then above them on my ranking are what I
call the master persuaders who have the
tools you know some combination of the
all those tools that you know the
commercial and the cognitive scientists
have but they also have this big
personality there's something maybe
about their situation it could be an
appetite for risk look at the amount of
abuse that Donald Trump willingly took
on I mean he knew this background we'd
be dug into he knew he was going to be
just savaged and he did it anyway and he
doesn't even look like he's ever having
a bad day alright you that's not learn
about in the easy way right so there's
something about his personality his risk
profile his bigger than life thing is
the fact he's a billionaire that gives
him that extra you know level of energy
one of the you know it's interesting
because and in the book I don't think
you you go into this which I and I bring
it up because it's interesting a lot of
people look at Trump and they say you
know this is a guy you know the the
stormy Daniels and I have one of the
things and you did talk about this where
there's a kind of scandal fatigue where
if you if you go to sleep for more than
eight hours you've missed three or four
Trump many scandals so it's like stormy
Daniels the porn star that he you know
that he may have had some kind of affair
with but then folded into that was that
she said that he asked to be spanked
with a copy of Forbes magazine and then
there were like two or three other many
I mean it's just like you you lose this
but people will say well he's an
arsonist and he doesn't he doesn't care
like he can't imagine a world in which
he is not the center are narcissists
better at being persuaders master
persuaders who are these totally
different things
narcissist tend to be better at being
leaders yeah so there's a pretty high
correlation between CEOs and leaders or
narcissists and you know I would argue
that that's not the bad news
it sounds like because especially if you
have such a transparent job as the
presidency there is no world where he
comes out okay by doing a bad job for
the country right he's locked in he's
got to make the country work or it just
doesn't work for his whatever narcissist
narcissistic tendencies he might have
part of being a master persuader and
certainly in Trump and I think this is
the the things that you were talking
about that actually got reasons
attention first were linguistic kill
shots
yeah define and give some examples of
linguistic culture well these are his
famous nicknames right or which I've now
started calling his forever names you
know when you get your forever name it
isn't going away folks you know your
lyin Ted forever so the the the first
one I that caught my attention of course
was a low-energy Jeb now I would like to
claim I'm gonna make this claim and I'm
pretty sure this would stand up to
fact-checking that I was the first
person on the planet who said that's the
end of Jeb that nickname is the end of
him now I don't think anybody else said
that right his only des time goes by
people realize how powerful that framing
was because Jeb went from in my mind
this calm collected executive kind of
persona that I said to myself man in an
emergency you want that guy he's not
gonna get you know he's unflappable and
everything but the moment you heard low
energy and he used another concept of
contrast because because his own energy
was so high you you couldn't you could
no longer see Jeb the same way and it
completely deflated his his campaign and
this was the the kind of tool that I saw
early on and said okay you know you
don't see what's coming this is way more
powerful and he had a little technique
that he would used to which is his
nicknames were you know unusual words
for politics so anything that's unusual
was a little stickier because you know
like oh that's unusual I'll remember
that
because we don't remember 99.99% of the
things around us
our brains are big enough you remember
the exceptions so he uses an exceptional
kind of word that you don't see in
politics and then he builds it so it's
it's designed for a future confirmation
every time you see Jeb you go yeah
compared to that Trump rally that's a
little low energy and then he did it
again with lyin Ted Cruz now because Ted
Cruz is a politician
in a political race somebody's going to
accuse him of lying so you know that
it's gonna get reinforced as you go but
the best part about it is that if you
were gonna cast a movie in which one of
the characters was a huge yeah a huge
liar and Ted Cruz came in for you know
to apply for the job you'd say take the
sign off the door we you know we we got
this beady-eyed bastard he looks like a
liar from you know from the get-go so
every time he said anything you thought
wasn't necessarily true and of course
they're all doing that you say Oh lyin
Ted lyin Ted and of course he put it
lyin with an apostrophe so he wanted to
make sure that it's not just a nickname
it's a brand right this is thick
likewise with crooked Hillary you knew
there would be stories about the Clinton
Foundation and emails and whatever so
that the crooked thing would be forever
reinforced as as he went and you know he
does this there's always a physical
element you know do they look at she
looked kind of bent over a little bit
you know what's a little crooked and and
you see that consistently there's the
visual there's the confirmation bias
there's a unique unique word it's not an
accident how does Trump get away with
you know speaking of Ted Cruz one of the
you know when Trump forwarded you know
kind of accounts or accusations that Ted
Cruz's father was somehow involved in
the JFK assassination which you know and
when I think about it like that's one of
the least bizarre and offensive things
right that that Trump said how does he
get away with that because that's
because he's doing persuasion in a world
where facts don't matter ya know
so all gonna remember that title so
early on in the election I was telling
people don't worry about the
fact-checking it's not going to hurt him
at all because facts don't matter we
simply don't use them to make decisions
we just sort of think we do it's an
illusion and that if he says something
that makes you question the viability of
somebody and it's not a fact that
feeling of unease stays with you even if
you say well it's not obviously you know
Ted Cruz's father was not part of this
but a little lingering thing but beyond
that he also does continue as a/b
testing he's putting stuff out here in
live rallies he's seeing the immediate
feedback he's testing it with his staff
you know they all say that he's like
running this by what do you think of
this what do you think of this and he's
picking the winners now the the Ted Cruz
dad thing wasn't a winner you just put
it out there see how it see how it
performs if other people had picked it
up if maybe the media on the right had
made a big deal about it it still
wouldn't be true but it would be giving
a little more persuasive talk about
anchors anchors as well as a tool of
persuasion and this is you know you and
you know and this is something that it's
kind of simultaneously hard to take
Trump seriously the more heat is part of
our lives or the bigger he gets I mean
he's the president but it's kind of hard
to take him seriously
he is a master persuader in your
parlance and then but he's really good
at negotiating anchors are part of that
talk about anchors yeah so most of you
know if you're going to negotiate you
want to come in with a with a big first
offer so you have the most room to to
move back but he also likes to make his
anchors visual so had he come in and
said well I'm the one who's going to be
strong on border security we're gonna
have a very you know a good system and
we'll we'll patch up the parts that need
to be patched you'd be I've had in a
minute so he doesn't do that he says
it's gonna be a wall and everybody says
I can't be a wall the whole way you know
there's all kinds of different reasons
why it can't be a wall and then he looks
at you goes
it's gonna be a wall walk it's a big
beautiful wall well the people who climb
over it just got 10 feet taller it's a
wall now exactly once I heard him say
well you know depending on the terrain
and stuff like that but he wisely just
stopped doing that right now he's doing
it because you know you sort of have to
be talking about the details but the the
visual of that was so powerful that he's
moved the country from well that's a
ridiculous idea to well we might have a
wall you know or at least some part of a
wall or we're talking about who's gonna
pay for it almost becomes a foregone
conclusion etc and you talk and this is
also really interesting and that he was
I mean he would say okay you know I'm
gonna get rid of 11 million people or 12
million people I'm building a giant wall
well they'll be a door in it and then we
won't send everybody out I mean so he
you throw at that anchor kind of it
could be visual or argumentative but
it's kind of like saying I want 50
million dollars and suddenly you feel
like you're doing well if you're only
giving him five million dollars yeah
what when he was asked is net worth and
of course mostly experts are saying well
it's probably between 3 and 5 billion
you know generously so he goes 10
billion and suddenly awhile goes by and
you sort of can't remember the other
numbers right you know and you might not
believe it's 10 but if you were to ask
people like after the fact after months
of going by you know estimate Trump's
net worth you would notice that the
average had started to get up closer to
10 you know they'd be wow it's not 10
but I'll bet it's 7 and they would have
forgotten that the experts said is
probably closer to 3 now part of and you
know this isn't what you're talking
about in the book because for instance
are you are you in favor of his
immigration policy as he talked about it
you know in its broadest terms of
stopping all you having emigrate legal
immigration getting rid of all illegal
immigration immigrants well I'm in favor
of keeping the folks who have been
living here as Americans you know that
you know just how the human
level right forget them so again I mean
you're not I mean it's not like you
actually want many of some of the
policies that he does I mean some of the
policies that he does or has articulated
or even put in place we're good from a
reason perspective sure they are from
you yours as well yeah the other crazy
thing I said early on is that you don't
worry about this immigration stuff that
these are his big first offers he just
wants to end up right-of-center
and as of today basically he's already
said I'll take your offer of keeping a
hundred thousand people in the country
and well just make it 1 million point
you know 1.8 million he's actually
keeping more people than their offer all
right so that's moving pretty far you
know to the middle and his courses base
is screaming but they're not gonna leave
him now he's pretty clever about that
and then his idea of having more of a
merit-based thing it seems to me that no
matter what system you had whether it
was lottery or merit-based
it's going to be racist in effect you
can't get away from it because even if
you said well we will just randomly do a
lottery you say well that's that's got
to be fair right except the only people
applying for the lottery are people who
have a certain amount of education they
know it exists they could get to America
they you know so it ends up being you
know more white people than people who
have never heard of the lottery so if
you accept that every solution is racist
and outcome and he says well why don't
we just take the people who will
immediately contribute and will be a
little selfish for America all you
really arguing at that point is the
value of selfishness for for your nation
and he does a reasonably good framing of
that too as he did in Davos and he goes
I'm gonna do what's good for America you
guys better be doing what's good for
your countries it's a friendly
competition right do as good as you can
for your country that's what we're doing
so what are the f I mean you discuss
this a bit but what are the ethics of
this type of persuasion or or that's
that's a separate issue so I fall into
the trap of not talking about ethics and
then people say oh you're in favor of
every unethical
which is not the case I talk about
persuasion as a tool and tools don't
have a good or a bad about them they're
just tools if if you are lying to
somebody to save their own life for
example I like to say when people say
but you're forgetting the ethical
considerations I say you know I would
lie to a terrorist to save your life
would you do the same for me you know
and people say well do the do the ends
justify the means to which I say always
always the ends of the ends justify the
means because everything you do is a
cost-benefit analysis now your opinion
of what is justified may be completely
different from mine but everybody does
what they think the ends will justify so
you know some of the argument is just
sophistry to bounce back briefly to
immigration AMA I'm an open borders type
of person I think that it I realize not
everybody will agree with me I don't
even agree with myself you know at least
three days out of the week but you know
I think anybody who wants to come here
who is not a criminal fleeing
prosecution or has a communicable
disease and depending on what it is you
know that even that's not a deal killer
but they should be able to come here and
work and live peacefully what would be
what's a counter to Trump's of your
performance on immigration like what
would be give me a master prison or
counter story but I believe he would not
I don't know this but I don't think he
would limit the number of people who
came in under a merit-based system
because you know we can use more
software engineers we can use well yeah
I mean the the GOP and he's he's
endorsed it as come out with an official
plan to it both in the Senate in the
house to cut legal immigration from
about a million a year to 500,000 but I
mean is there a you know how do you have
how do you counter somebody like Trump
do you go toe to toe or counter camera
for what purpose I guess to to force him
into a cognitive dissonance move you
know I mean like you know
in the current climate it seems like
he's unstoppable because nobody is up to
his level but surely there must be ways
to counter what he's doing it would
depend on the topic so you'd have to you
have to sort of dig down on the specific
topic but everything pretty much
everything has a counter right one way
or another the the immigration thing
most of us don't really understand the
immigration like we don't understand
most of the big topics you know very few
people could sit down and detail all the
ins and outs of immigration and when you
say for example he wants to cut it from
a million to half a million I don't know
the right number mm-hmm how would I you
know is can we absorb that many people
easily if we can I say two million right
right but I don't know does anybody know
my guess is that cutting it from a
million to half a million may have to do
with they just assume that the merit
will be kind of tough to you know
there'll be a high bar to cross I'm
guessing in terms of the actual election
you don't vote right okay but you did at
various points and towards the the you
know as I guess Trump's critics would
say as America was going down the tubes
you endorsed in rapid succession you
endorsed Hillary Clinton then you
endorsed Trump then you briefly endorsed
Gary Johnson you know and then you went
back to endorsing Trump what was going
on that explained that kind of quick
Domino
so keep in mind that the endorsements
were not my predictions the prediction
was was Trump the endorsements
originally I was not endorsing anybody I
was just writing about Trump but because
I wrote about him people associated me
with him and they started calling me on
social media Joseph Goebbels you know
[Music]
killers PR guy now given that people
believe that Trump was actually going to
be as bad as Hitler like not in a you
know not in a hyperbole way but but
actually would do horrible things
putting me in that same sentence is
marking me for death and I mean that in
an actual literal
Cole sentence because let me tell you if
one of you were an actual Hiller and
about to become you know leader of the
country and do all kinds of Hillary
stuff and I had you in a room alone I'd
kill you right well yeah I'd kill you
and I'd be pretty happy about it too so
once people believed literally that that
the world was going to come apart if he
got elected and I would be part of that
in their view it was dangerous and you
saw in Northern California of people
getting attacked leaving Trump rallies
etc so I briefly used my own powers of
persuasion to say all right I endorse
Hillary Clinton I'm sure Trump's gonna
win but I endorse Hillary Clinton almost
immediately when you know that word
started getting out the critics just
went away
because they didn't care why I was on
their team or even that it was not
serious but it still worked exactly as I
imagined it would but then toward the
end you know I wanted to be on the
winning team and I said alright uh you
know she said something about estate
taxes she would tax me to the point that
I considered confiscating you couldn't
afford to die
in mortality wasn't my first choice yeah
but and so for that reason so in my case
every dollar I made for the rest of my
life she she would have taken seventy
five cents right because half of it I
pay when I make it and then she would
have taken another half from my estate
so I said well I can't live with that so
I endorsed Trump but then that was right
before the famous Access Hollywood tape
dropped and for about a week or two I
endorsed Garry Johnson just to find a
safe space and my my reasoning was that
you know Garry Johnson only touches
himself and so that felt like it just
felt like a safer place to be and you
know and you didn't know where aleppo
was and he was a stoner and I thought
I've gotten so much in common with him
he's my guy but toward the end I fully
embraced the Trump candidacy without
embracing the the politic can you
predict how the next three years are
likely to play out and also you know we
have midterm elections coming up which
people and and political scientists are
saying it's likely that the Democrats
just from structural reason for
structural reasons will probably regain
the house probably not the Senate etc
but like you know what do you see
happening can we you know I mean at some
point do we just become tired of Trump
and tune him out or well let me let me
build up to that answer so I'd also
predicted prior to inauguration that the
following arc would play out in the
first year that they would start with
marching in the streets oh my god we've
elected Hitler or he's Hitler but after
a few months of not doing Hitler stuff
they'd start thinking well let's say
something else about him there's chaos
in the White House he's incompetent his
team is you know team is bad and that
sort of lasted through summer and this
is exactly what I predicted a year
before that happened and then I said
that by the end of the year when they
started doing the year-end reviews of
you know what's happened they will be
forced to admit and this is how I worded
it that he's effective even if you don't
like what he's doing so he got his
judges he's got the economy going he cut
the cut the regulations you watch TV
you've seen the whole list by the end of
the year his resume was looking really
good for the things he promised he would
do which is probably how you need to
score it so so I nailed the first year
which I don't think anybody else was
saying that saying anything along those
lines and I would say that the next
three years I'm actually predicting what
I'm calling a golden age and I'm
defining that as a point when everything
is moving in the right direction so I
think we're going to have a strong
economy I think there's a nonzero chance
that North Korea will will lead to maybe
a Malta you know a shared Nobel Prize I
think that's possible
it might be about the same time at the
end of the year that Trump is being
impeached
you know if the Democrats get their way
but I think you're you already seen Isis
defeated you've seen you know between
Isis and the economy and if North Korea
gets under control technology is doing
wonderful things I think it's a golden
age it might be the best I think people
are gonna say it was the best time that
of their lives you you heard it here
first we're gonna hold you to that we're
gonna come through the audience for Q&A
in a minute
you know this and I'm also remembering a
an interview you did with Virginia
posture all reason in the 90s that where
you were talking about various things
what how important do you think politics
are to everyday life you know we're in
the Bay Area I've spent the past week
and and and my colleagues we were
interviewing people who are doing
fantastic things in technology you know
what what ultimately what is more
important that drives progress and and
fairness and and goodness in the world
is it politics or is it technology or
business or what
probably communication the the fact that
anything good gets everywhere pretty
quickly and so you can share your ideas
the in the in the marketplace of ideas
the good ideas can eat the bad ideas
more efficiently than they could when
you had to write a letter you know so I
would say the the communication ability
we have is really drives everything let
me follow up on that one of the things
that is really fascinating and I don't I
don't know how many of you are on
Twitter regularly but you do these I and
this was one of the most remarkable
things I saw that you were doing over
the past few years where you will do
periscope kind of interviews or
transmissions dispatches with with your
followers you know I mean you'll get 30
or 40 or 50,000 people to watch you
talking into the phone and I saw one
where I think you were on in Veit on
vacation and Switzerland or something
yeah but you
to talk to your audience for like an
hour so and about a year or so ago I
talked to a Interactive Media Studies
professor named Glenn Platt who was
talking about the intimacy economy where
new forms of communication are actually
shrinking the gap between kind of the
star the author or the producer the you
know the great person up on the stage
the priest and the audience and
periscope seems to be doing that why did
you start doing that and what you know
what do you get out of it and what does
your audience get out of this because I
mean it's really remarkable and again
you know apart from the content it's the
medium it's really fascinating yeah so
periscope if you if you don't know what
it is it's just you can just turn it on
with an app and you can talk to anybody
you're the only one talking but you can
see their comments going by so you can
interact with them that way it's the
most intimate mass broadcasting thing
because as I'm talking people are
simultaneously commenting and that there
and they're influencing me so I like to
think of it as being like this big
collective mind because I'll say well I
think this might work but I got this
question does anybody know how this
works and the comet just Scrolls by in
real-time so my brain is like jacked in
to 30,000 people at the same time and
I'm you know I'm kind of the focus the
center of that but I have access to all
of their intelligence in a real-time but
I'm also talking to just a you know a
screen which is usually a picture of
myself they show you yourself instead of
the audience because there's lots of
them and it's very personal and people
feel like they are actually talking to
me in real time and I you know have my
coffee with them and that's part of the
hypnosis by the way it's branded coffee
with Scott Adams and I have them do a
simultaneous sip because once they
connect that their love of coffee with
this periscope it Adickes them to it and
and they do say that by the way that's
the most common common comment I get so
the reason I do it is I was looking for
ways to extend my influence and what I
was talking about the election and
potato
about Trump and it was one of many
things I just tried I tried YouTube I
tried Twitter tried everything but you
know for every form of communication
you're there's a personality that fits
it perfectly and it turns out it just
fit my personality perfectly so that's
why I use it what I get from it is it's
exciting every time I turn it on I I
just love it and the people I'm
interacting with like it and this is
just great energy thing final question
and then we're going to go to you guys
for some some questions
yeah end the book with a kind of curious
anecdote about election night and the
BBC and you say that you had forgotten
earlier sometime before the election you
had promised the BBC that you would do
an interview on election night when it
became clear you know who was winning or
losing and of course England is ahead of
us so they were up and added and you
said that you talked to the BBC after
enjoying a large amount of California's
finest medical marijuana and my question
for you is are you still high well I'll
tell you that the BBC doesn't ask me for
interviews anymore the part you left out
is that you know it was this amazing
night for me because I had predicted
this event so well by the time I went to
bed high end of my mind and then it's
like after midnight in the phone rings
I'm like I'd better see what that is
hello it's the BBC you'll be on in you
know a moment I'm like perfect great
let's do this and I I believe I said
something but I don't know what it was
it's yeah we're gonna have to look that
up and just see if it's like okay well
let's turn it over to questions Melissa
man is going to bring a microphone and
please how about the gentleman right
there Bob and wait until the bike comes
to you yeah I had very two very short
questions one you mentioned peggy noonan
as a master persuader and I thought
maybe you could elaborate on that
I was struck me as very interesting I
read her as well and the other was to
ask you what would Oprah be like in your
2020 election scenario yes and we also
have to rock it's in play as well
Dwayne Johnson so Peggy Noonan one of
the best writers of politics ever wrote
for Reagan I think she also wrote The
Shining Hill on the you know she said
they the boys of pond talk of the
Normandy speech that Reagan gave as well
as the thousand points of light that age
does yeah very much so and notice that
their visual you know she's a visual
persuader but you just look at her
writing and it just it's it's different
you know she's just not like a normal
writer the question was Oprah yeah well
I when that first came up I said Oprah
is too smart to do this but she's also
smart enough to make us think she might
because and I think her Golden Globe
speech was along those lines now maybe
she was feeling you down as if you know
if the if the country had risen as one
and said well you know we just proclaim
you leader baby she would have done well
I think that's where her her heart is
and I think that Trump would rip her
apart in that it just wouldn't be a fair
fight
how about what we're gonna come up right
there yes we'll get to you next
Thank You thanks sorry hey Scott thank
you two quick questions one oh wait
earlier tonight you talk about merits
and you talk about men not being happy
is that because they're married to women
I'm married to a man and I'm very happy
so maybe that's the issue you're all a
lying second Redford we talk about
rhetoric right and rhetoric is just that
we don't care about rhetoric we care
about results so our people going to at
the end of the day you top off the
Golden Age we care about the results and
is that what's going to get us to vote
for Trump again
yeah I mean there's there's nothing like
success to put people on your side and I
think if the economy stays strong and
there's no there are no new surprises
except for the stormy Daniel type which
is really baked into the cake at this
point he's gonna be hard to beat
assuming he wants to run I've been
saying that his sense of theater could
drive him to do one amazing term if it
turned out to be amazing and then leave
on top because if you wait eight years
something Bad's gonna happen that isn't
your fault right there's gonna be a war
or there's gonna be something that's
going to be tagged on your legacy
so his sense of theater might get him
out in four plus his age you know he's
immortal he may he may know that's the
factor do you want to touch the marriage
question there well I understand you
said that you're married to a man and
you're very happy was that the
presumption does he have a brother my
girlfriend is here by the way next
question Melissa where did you what
subjects are you discussing on periscope
today it's almost always about some
Trump persuasion related things so
immigration lately you know that so it's
really whatever's the headline and one
of the things I can do with this by the
way is because I'm a trained persuader
if I frame something first it's really
sticky and and it's more because I'm
first and because I have these tools so
as soon as I see a news story I can be
on periscope within the hour
framing it and you'll see my frames some
sometimes you know on the on the news
and it's not a coincidence because most
of the news producers and on-air talent
follow my periscope so so I in front run
the news
next question oh there you go
quick question for you concerning Trump
if you were gonna guess or if you have
an opinion about it what percentage
would you say that Trump uses in his
master persuasion techniques which is
conscious directed logical and what
percentage is unconscious just
accidental and serendipitous
so persuasion is a little like learning
to type without looking at your fingers
meaning that when you start you do have
to think about it every time it's like
oh I'm gonna make somebody think pass to
say hello I'm gonna use a visual imagery
but at some point it's automatic so when
people say is it like just you know an
instinct is he just you know unnatural
well as sort of somewhere in between
these are clearly skills he learned and
he wrote the book art of the deal and
and when you see how often he makes you
think past the sale you know we're gonna
build a wall and Mexico is going to pay
for it right
the Mexico is going to pay for it is
just to make you think there's gonna be
a wall and you're only talking about
who's paying for it well you see how
often he does it there's no way that
it's you know accidental but it's
probably close to automatic because it's
just something he knows how to do at
this point in the back yeah so Scott to
what extent has this conversation about
politics displaced your work on Dilbert
are you are you do you find this is your
future or are you trying to balance the
two how do you think about it well I
think my future about talking about this
topic may be only as long as Trump's
future because he's what makes this fun
so I still do my full Dilber thing as I
always did I just added this on top so
it's been a busy few years wait before
we go to the next question let's focus
on Dilbert for a second you've been
doing it now I mean since 89 or it was
first published in 89 how do you how do
you maintain that that's a that's a long
haul well
I guess the first thing I'd say is it's
still easier than all of your jobs so
but it doesn't pay as well I I made a
promise to myself that when Dilbert
started working that I would never
complain about oh I've got to draw a
cartoon it's my my work is so hard when
you know there's somebody at the the
smelting plant you know good yeah so so
first of all it's easy and second of all
nothing's easy if you do a lot of it
right you can get pretty pretty sick of
it but it's always a new topic so
there's never a Dilbert that's exactly
like the one I did what what do you
think of people like I guess Burt breath
adore Gary Larson I mean these are or
captive creator of calvin and hobbes
caesar's cleaner it's like quitters okay
well then I guess I do what are you
offended by them or you should they
drive whatever train they're on you know
like into the ocean no matter what or I
don't understand them
say this so you know Watterson for
example quit because the job was really
hard the way he did it because he'd use
like a little tiny paintbrush and it was
just a little bad process I do it on a
computer and cut and paste and but he
did it because he thought his artistic
you know arcade hit its zenith and he
was gonna you know go out before it
became sad and I thought to myself
you're doing this for other people they
still want to see it
like you know why can't you sell people
things they want you know I didn't
understand the selfishness of it I guess
that's a interesting inversion yes
assuming a let's say a decent economy of
the next three years which Democrat has
the best chance of beating Trump and why
if you were going to make a prediction
and separately
is there any Democrat out there that you
would call the the Trump Democrat
meaning they have that power of
persuasion fast answer is nope
there's nobody at a sort of a national
consciousness level that even comes
close if George Clooney could escape is
a Hollywood situation which he can't
write there's probably just too much
stuff there to to do it he actually has
the skill if you listen to a George
Clooney interview where he's talking
about politics you're gonna see you're
gonna see some master persuader stuff
and I don't know where he came by it but
it's pretty palpable to people who know
this stuff so he could do it if he
hadn't had the you know the Hollywood
stuff but maybe even that's not enough
to stop when you say the Hollywood stuff
what do you mean just like his
obligations and things like no I mean by
the time the opposition research people
got into him you know they'd find 50
examples of me to know and you know it
doesn't it doesn't hurt Trump because he
came to us saying I'm no angel literally
with those words I'm no angel I'm
bringing a certain set of skills to you
you know this is my package but if you
do the hypocritical path you're just
doomed so but no there's there's nobody
obvious that has charisma are there any
Republicans because you know there's a a
large group of Republicans who are kind
of you know anti Trump or never Trump
errs gosh
not really you know part of it is he he
breaks the curve so badly you know if
you hold him in your mind everybody else
just disappears you know I talked in the
book about how pence was a brilliant
choice because you want to you want a
vice president who seems qualified Pence
has you know on paper all the
qualifications but he looks like the
washdown version of the main person you
know if you took everything that's
interesting away from Trump
you'd have pence which is just that's
that's like a perfect choice because you
you know he's like just the spare tires
like the harshness and actually
funniness of that comet reminded me a
bit of another point that you make in
the book and this
something that we share in that we're
both from New York I was born in
Brooklyn Scott was born and raised in
upstate New York and you you talk about
Trump Trump is first love is very funny
which very few people especially people
who dislike and give it credit for but
he also is a very New York sense of
humor as opposed to a California sense
of humor and discuss a little bit about
that and how does that play you know you
talk about in New York California but
then there's also Texas which is this
other third kind of point of cultural
significance yeah I can't speak as well
to Texas but I've been in New York and
I've been in California and there's a
big difference about what people think
is funny in New York sense of humor and
of course it's a gross generalization
doesn't doesn't apply to every person is
there something funny about saying
something that's terrible
so if you if you remember Trump's
comment about McCain and the other side
as McCain's a war hero and Trump said
well I prefer the ones that didn't get
caught now now first of all he's using
the two of six rule of humor which is
you need without getting into it you
need two dimensions before something
registers as funny and two of the
dimensions are something you know
naughty or awful which you know that
comment was and the other is clever yeah
there are a few other dimensions but he
combined those two things in a classic
joke form and then realized probably
after the fact people don't get this as
joke it's not and people said that he's
being disrespectful to became but if
you're from New York you understand that
to be opposite of what was happening the
reason it was funny is because you don't
make fun of veterans and you certainly
don't make fun of a P Oh w-who you know
served this country and everything else
so because it was so awful that's why it
was a joke
and you know of course he can also get
away with it because he was good for
veterans and stuff but if you thought
that was just a disrespectful you've
missed the shell you know this it's a
pretty good show if you know that he's
joking so what I mean is is the country
divided between kind of New York and
California sensibilities or them what
what happens to there's the midwest
where a lot of people live and and
there's texas which seems to be
something else how does how does that
kind of factory well having not lived in
too many places that i would imagine
that the midwest puts more of a premium
on being nice and that probably works
against them a little bit but not enough
to prevent him from winning just about
every every state including a couple
there were several democratic
strongholds that hillary didn't even
campaign it
she took it I would like Wisconsin okay
let's have another question and for one
more name okay great
well this will be it at the beginning of
the night you talked about how you were
left to the left but then you talked
about how you thought Trump might offer
in a new golden era so I'm having
trouble understanding that and I had a
pretty straight question do you think
Trump's policies are good for America
well let's let's look at his policy for
Isis that seemed to be good his economic
policies seem to be working his
immigration policy if he guess what he
wants we still get lots of immigrants
but they're the kind that can contribute
more easily so it's good for America
while being bad for the people who
didn't get to come here may be bad for
the countries that we drain their talent
from I would say that he's he promised
us a selfish approach America first and
I don't know how you could argue that
he's the you know you can't argue that
he's not delivering that could you would
be an example of something that's not
good economy is good Oh give me an
example I would argue that if you're
looking at it from an economic
perspective you probably have a good
argument there but this is a persuasion
game and his persuasion game is second
to none and we don't know how that's
going to play out so the the mere fact
that he can threaten some companies with
a trade war makes other companies say
well maybe
won't reach so far you know so it has a
dampening effect on a lot of places I
don't think you can do a straight
economic analysis of that so and but I
would put that in the category of things
I'm not an expert on that so it would be
hard for me to have an opinion on
whether those the tariffs are a good or
bad idea what about those social issues
then because he you know he certainly
he's come out as very anti-abortion or
reproductive rights he seems to kind of
play footsie with alt right kind of
racist elements you know does that sit
well with you as an extreme liberal well
the the second one the all right stuff
is more about the politics that's not
really a policy so and the question was
about policy there's no question he's
offended a huge swath of the country
we're very unhappy about living here
I don't diminish that at all and indeed
you know I'm making it a personal effort
to try to fix that so I I'm doing a
number of things behind the scenes to
directly address that there be a Dilbert
story arc about abortion
probably not but let me so let me
clarify them president Trump just wants
the federal government not to be in the
business of deciding that would leave it
to the states and if this situation had
happened 30 years ago maybe some of the
states given their way would make it
illegal but I think today they'd have a
tough time attracting industry to other
state if they made that illegal so I
think the practical impact of his
personal opinion about abortion we may
never see it well and same with drug
legalization where during the campaign
he actually said the state should decide
at which Jeff Sessions is Attorney
General is kind of you know argued with
him about that but it's but they're not
going after resin so there may be a
persuasion play here that hasn't
unfolded yet because he sometimes
sometimes you have to break something
before he can fix it and nothing would
break the marijuana situation harder
than Jeff session coming after somebody
in California and closing down a
dispensary and for not a good reason
other than it's illegal
the
world would blow up so he may be trying
to break something don't know yet what
we will leave it there thank you so much
Scott Adams
[Applause]
[Music]